good afternoon everybody and welcome to
this licensing act 2003 hearing of mid
suffolk district council
it's the 14th of september
this subcommittee is called to hear an
application for a new premises license
for the chequers inn
at 19 stone market road great blake and
ipswich
in accordance with regulations 15 and 16
of the 2005 hearing regulation certain
parties have a right to make
representations on licensing
applications and attend the application
hearing we've had representations from
a responsible authority being the
environmental protection team of uh
midsummit council and other persons uh
being the neighbours mr and mrs scott
i'll quickly go through the uh the
procedure that we'll follow
um
there's a few um
bits and pieces that we need to do some
technicalities on the procedure but
generally speaking the the licensing
officer will present a report outlining
the application
the applicant will then
present the application
the responsible authority will then have
their opportunity to make their
representations
and then lastly uh mr scott as the other
person may ever be able to make his
representations after each presentation
there will be an opportunity to ask
questions
i just want to reiterate that it's
questions that you'll be asking on the
the presentation that you've just heard
you will all have an opportunity to have
your say at that specific times but if
you can just keep um when
things
items to questions um
when uh when asked to
then finally the applicant will sum up
his case
and uh there's any final questions for
members uh that they can be taken the
the members will then go into private
session to determine the application
council guthrie is the chairman of the
the full licensing and regulatory
committee and as uh sitting on this
subcommittee is going to chair
the subcommittee this afternoon so over
to you council guthrie thank you
thank you nigel well welcome good
afternoon my name is kathy guthrie and
as you've heard i will be chairing the
meeting today
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be brought class live
to youtube and be capable of repeated
viewing
the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consented to being recorded
by the council and the possible use of
those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public
and press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
virtual meeting etiquette
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt the other
speakers
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by myself as the
chair so please await your turn
so do we have apologies for absence
please
an unreceived chair
and declaration of interests by
councillors are there any declarations
none
none thank you
so we'll have introductions
first of all obviously there's myself
counselor kathy guthrie as chair
and then
councillor dave muller would you
put your hand up or something say hello
yes good afternoon everybody thank you
thank you and councillor gerard brewster
as well please
yeah
we see you could not hear you but we
know you're there when needed you need
to
yeah
it is difficult to remember to do that i
mean it takes a time doesn't it
so let's introduce the officers we've
already met nigel
de lou who is our legal representative
um kay would you like to introduce
yourself please yes
okay sanders license not for that thank
you
and catherine please
uh catherine green licensing officer
thank you and kerry chandler
please kerry chandler licensing officer
thank you
and we have um andy
oh no we have um
emma rich bell our
assistant manager food there you are
good afternoon everyone yes emma
richbell i'm assistant manager for food
safety and licensing
thank you and our committee officer
karen sayer where are you there you are
good afternoon governance officer karen
sayer thank you very much indeed for
that
so
now mr lang if you'd like to introduce
yourself and if you are represented um
would you like to introduce anyone else
whom you might have with you so
over to you thank you
um hello everyone on uh david lang i've
been
the landlord of the checkers since 1994
first all as a tenant and then to be a
lease holder with
um
punch
who were formerly of pub master
and i bought a freehold in 2014
and since then i've completely
refurbished the pub as you can see if
you've done this just to introduce your
good self we'll we'll give you your
opportunity to speak but that was a very
helpful introduction because there's
quite a lot there for it okay
and do you have anyone else representing
you or is it just yourself oh just me
just you thank you very much indeed
um
and we now have a responsible authority
andy ruston edwards would you like to
introduce yourself please good afternoon
andy ruxin edwards senior environment
protection officer
thank you
now mr lang will you confirm that you've
you understand the receipt of the
procedure and you've had the report and
copies of all the representations
yes
you have
and so um we do have other people
present now it's mr scott would you like
to introduce yourself please
[Music]
hello yes my name is guy scott
i'm a four kingfisher drive great
blakenum
thank you very much
and
do you want anyone else to represent you
is it yourself representing your just
yourself
it's just myself and my wife is here if
needed
lovely thank you very much indeed and
her name is and don't say yes scott
julia how do you do thank you very much
right
so does anyone in the party of this
hearing wish to withdraw their
application or representation so uh mr
lane do you wish to withdraw anything
uh no
i'm mr scott
no
thank you very much
[Music]
so
my question is to the licensing officer
presenting the case have there been any
requests from the parties for permission
to call witnesses
no chair
thank you
and have the parties indicate they wish
to present any documentary or other
material as evidence
yes chair and the applicant applicant
has confirmed that he does not wish the
material to be presented at today's
hearing
and that's the material that was
presented by mr scott
thank you
[Music]
but we now need to just estimate the
time so i will ask you mr lang how long
do you think it'll be for you to present
your case please
um
couple minutes
oh a couple of minutes all right okay um
mr scott have you got your microphone on
because there's something gurgling
that's coming in
thank you sorry it just interrupts i
don't know why i don't know what it is
right okay so that's that
um and in fact i do actually need to ask
you mr scott how long do you think it
will take you to present uh your
evidence please
uh 10 15 minutes
thank you
and nigel do i inquire of um andy
ruston edwards at all or not
yes please
yes so andy ruston edwards can you tell
us how long your evidence will be please
uh i believe five minutes should be
thank you very much for that
so
we're happy with that and i think that's
reasonable for all of us isn't it so we
can move on
so if you would then kay um i'm now
going to ask you as the licensing
officer to present your report m oblique
l a sub 21 1 and to summarise the matter
under consideration if you would over to
you thank you thank you
this hearing is to determine an
application made for the grant of a new
premise license made under section 17 of
the licensing act 2003 by the chequers
great blakenum limited in relation to
the premise the chequers in 19 stone
market road great blackening
the application was received by the
licensing authority on the 22nd of july
2021 and a copy of this is attached to
this report as appendix a
the application made has been subject to
the statutory consultation period as
described by regulation the notice is
advertising the application have been on
display at the premise and published in
the ipswich star on the 23rd of july
2021 edition
full details of the proposed activities
and timings are contained within the
application form attached as appendix a
the operating schedules steps proposed
by the applicant to promote the four
licensing objectives are listed in part
m of the application form the premise
currently hold a premise license which
was granted in 2005. the application for
a new premise license is required due to
the expansion of the site
a hearing is necessary to determine the
application following receipt of
representations which have not been
withdrawn
the subcommittee will be aware that its
consideration is confined to the
promotion of the four licensing
objectives and the need or commercial
demand for licensed premises are not
considerations for the licensed
authority when discharging its licence
and functions
the licensing authority must carry out
its functions under the act with a view
of proporting the four licensing
objectives which are the prevention of
primary disorder public safety the
prevention of public nuisance and the
protection of children from harm
where revisions are made to the
legislation or guidance issued by the
secretary of state there may be a period
of time when the local statement of
license and policies is inconsistent
with these revisions in these
circumstances the licensing authority
will have regard and give appropriate
way to the relevant changes
guidance and its own statement of
licence and policy
the subcommittee will also be aware of
the human rights act 1998 considerations
just
article six for the applicant and
articles eight and one of protocol one
for those raising representations when
determining applications for the grant
of a new license
the licensing authority has received one
representation from environmental
protection being a responsible authority
under the license in act 2003 this is
attached to the report as appendix d
there has been one representation
received made by other persons which
includes local residents businesses or
residents association this is attached
as appendix c to this report
the subcommittee must having regard to
the representations made take
such of the steps if any as it considers
appropriate for the promotion of the
licensing objectives
they are
to grant the license subject to
conditions which are consistent with the
operating schedule accompanying this
application modified to such an extent
as the authority considers appropriate
for promotion of the licensing
objectives and subject to any mandatory
conditions which must be included in the
license
to exclude from the scope of the license
any of the licensable activities to
which the application relates to refuse
to specify a person
in the license as a premise supervisor
or to reject the application
for these purposes conditions of the
license are modified if any of them are
altered or omitted or any new condition
is added
any party agreed by the decision taken
by the licensing authority in respect of
this application has a statutory right
of appeal to the magistrate's court this
concludes my summary thank you chair
thank you for that k
mr lane do you have any questions to the
officer
no thank you
um and i will come back to mr scott in a
minute but i will ask um members of the
committee uh councillor muller do you
have any questions
none at all thank you chair
and councillor brewster
could you just unmute your mic so that
the public can hear you
apologies
um no i have no at the moment fine thank
you very much indeed uh mr scott do you
have any questions
the officer
not at this stage now
thank you very much
and um mr andy justin edwards do you
have any questions at all no i don't
have any questions
thank you very much indeed
so ms lang if you'd like to
[Music]
present your case and we'll hear from
you directly thank you very much
all right everyone um so as i said
before i
started off as a tenant in 1994
um with pub master club master was
bought
by punch and
um in 2003 i took on lease
uh
after
a few years i started to inquire about
purchasing the freehold and
purchased the freehold in 2014.
since then i've completely refurbished
pub
and we pride ourselves on holy standards
we won best pub of the year
uh
we certainly don't in allow any swearing
or excessive drinking the pub has always
had a children's player
um
we
we have not had a karaoke in 15 years
um
we entertain
we had some entertainment in the summer
when we were on your later overnight
doors um
any functions upstairs always food led
okay and
yeah i feel the
letter of objection is
very much fabricated and factually
incorrect
there must be three thousand residents
in great lakeman
um we've only one complaint on
thank you for that
um
councillor mueller do you have
any questions
uh no questions at this stage
counselor brewster
can you unmute yourself please
um
do you experience any problems with with
uh noise and so on uh from your angle
uh no
we're as i said we're a food led pub we
don't have entertainment very often
maybe
half a dozen times in a year calendar
year
um
so no we don't have
you know
uh reason to cause any complaint on the
football
okay thank you
um well
i will ask um let's first of all
see
um
i think in fairness to mr scott do you
have any questions at this stage
to ask the applicant
yes mr lane
how can you say that you don't have live
entertainment within your pub
on a regular basis when you actually
advertise it on your website
we might advertise that we don't
we don't have i mean how often do you
call regular i mean
every other month i do not call regular
it's
three months sorry sometimes every three
months that's even less
ev every month not three months every
night we have we definitely don't have
everything something on every month for
you sure do not um can we can we just
stick to sort of questions of what we've
been told i know i know you you're
obviously not happy with the response
but if you have questions that would be
great you know just so that we can
understand what the issue is
so
any further questions
yes there are further questions yes
um
the the issues are that the
pub has now been extended considerably
it needs to be a question you will have
your your say in a moment and you can
make all these representations but
unless you just have a specific question
of mr lane as to what he's just said um
then we'll we'll move on to your part
and when it comes to your turn to make
your representations you can sell that
in a few moments
okay all right i'll say that in a few
moments thank you
all right thank you very much indeed um
mr andy ruston do you have any questions
for the applicant at all
i do chair yes if i may yes please mr
lang you said you're you're not aware of
any uh noise issues from the pub are you
aware of the abatement notice served on
the pub in regards to noise nuisance
caused to neighbouring properties
um yeah of course i am but as for from
mr scott i don't know
right the notice was served by the local
authority i have no further questions i
just wanted to check that mr lang was
aware of the notice that was served in
the pub
yes i am of course
thank you
thank you very much
um
[Music]
and the licensing officers do you have
any further questions for the applicant
at all
no chair
right
um
i think my questioning will come a
little later when i've heard a little
bit more because we seem to be a bit
short on sort of information here at the
moment so i'll reserve my right to speak
and ask questions further
so with mr scott would you like to
present your case to the committee so
that we can sorry it should be the
responsible authority who comes next
oh i beg your pardon that's mr henley
sorry beg your pardon
would you like to present your case to
us please thank you
thank you chair i'm making this
representation on behalf of my colleague
david harold as he's on leave at the
moment so
the application came to us for
comments and you've got the item there i
believe the representation from our from
our team
objecting to the hours that are proposed
we have a current
noise nuisance case ongoing regarding
the pub and
music from the pub itself
and an abatement notice was served
on the pub in terms of
the music levels not being controlled
to a satisfactory level and we asked for
conditions on there that the doors and
windows are closed
during any
any performance happening
the applicant
would like to extend the hours that he's
he's currently operating at the pub in
the representation my colleague referred
to the hours
being increased in the this application
whereas in fact the hours are going to
be reduced but the hours
looking at being increased are
not in line with their current planning
permission for that part of the pub
i know it's not licensing issue it's
just to make you aware that the reason
we're looking at this and we've objected
is because there is a breach of
potentially breach of planning but
that's another matter but we're looking
at noise nuisance which is why the
abatement notice has been served
we don't believe that the
the applicant is able to control the
noise coming from the premises
at the current hours
that he's operating and we would like to
see the the hours reduced to
as it says in there 2300
and possibly even more
restricting the hours even tighter for
the outside area
we would like to
possibly ask for conditions
to control those hours and again control
the noise levels at the boundary of the
pub and the boundary of the newest
residential
premises
sorry i'm just shuffling some paperwork
here
so i
i don't know if you'd like us to put
forward our proposals for the
the conditions we like at the moment or
if it's just to
make that presentation i've just
done on behalf of mr harold
nigel should we have that now while
we've got it all at once yes that's fine
the setting that set out in the written
representation so yeah be happy to hear
them
so in the application
there's just referral to controlling the
noise levels so that it's not causing a
nuisance at the nearest residential
premises and this looks to be determined
by the operator of the dps of the pub
the concern is that
as it stands currently he's not able to
determine a level he
that is reasonable
nearby premises so we'd be looking at
working with him to
set a level at the boundary
usually it would be looking at
background level and no more than 5 db
above that background level up to a
certain time and possibly then no
exceedance of the background level
after a certain hour depending on what
hours you're going to permit to operate
so it would be something we'd be looking
at working with him
again to be agreed by local authority
officers
other options would be a noise limiter
but we don't think foolish would be
actually fair to install this equipment
at extra cost when it's easily
controllable by having a
limit set at the boundary
again during live music and recorded
music
the applicant would like to have the
doors closed after 21 30.
from previous complaints the complaints
have shown that the levels prior to this
time are still also causing a statutory
nuisance
so we would like to see in that
any conditions that
the the doors are closed at all times
whenever it's live
and recorded music
being played
also we'd like to see on there no
external speakers
so no speakers on the patio area or
outside the pub at all to relay any
music
and they are the only the comments i had
on there now representation
thank you for that
um
so um
to your good self uh mr lang do you have
um
a uh
a question
to mr rutsen edwards at all about what
you've just heard or any comment or
something
yes yeah i'm happy to work with all of
that that sounds fine
thank you for that
um counselor mueller do you have any
questions
uh nonetheless president thank you chair
thank you and councillor brewster
no i have none either at the moment
um i did make a note but i think you
covered it mr ups and edwards that you
would like to work with um the applicant
um which
seemed hopeful because i had made a note
that i didn't know what the levels were
and who was
assessing them
so that was something that you answered
in your presentation there so thank you
for that
and um
mr scott do you have any questions with
regard to um mr watson edward's
presentation
uh none with regards to the sound you
know there's no mention in there of the
um the smells
right okay well we'll wait until we hear
from you to sort of follow that through
for you is that all right
thank you and um
plan the um licensing officers kay do
you have any questions at all regarding
that
right i know it's going out in a funny
order but i'm sort of looking at people
on the screen to make sure i've got
everybody right
um so i think we now need to hear from
mr scott if we may please could you put
your presentation forward thank you
before you do what is that noise that's
that's interrupting your your microphone
there's a there's a large hissing noise
it's probably the rain to be fair
oh no it's raining really is it
okay right i wondered what it was
sorry about that there's nothing i can
do about that one yeah good afternoon
thank you for letting us attend this
hearing um i hope you've all had a
chance to read through the evidence that
we presented is that the case
absolutely
um
the photographs that were submitted had
notes attached to the wallets when we
submitted them but if you don't have
these as we didn't in the pack we
received if you've got any questions i'm
quite happy to answer them
on what the photos indicate
um we have lived in this house for
30 years just over an hour and have
always been aware that we had the
checkers pub at the end of the garden
um
we have had a few issues with the pub
over the past few years
but when it was a tied public house
it was always quite easy to get
issues resolved
over the last five years
and certainly since mr lang has owned
the pub
it is no longer a quiet village pub
when mr lang had the extensions built he
told us that he was extending it to have
a restaurant stroke gastro pub
but this does not seem to be the case
it is turning into an events venue
the building has not been designed for
this purpose of discos bands live music
quizzes and other amplified events like
we had the football a little while ago
and it is far too close to the
neighboring properties and the late
nights and early hours of the morning
when there is still music and people in
the gardens
is having a very serious effect on both
our health and our well-being
the constant noise from its customers
and behaviour at certain times is very
unreasonable the shouting and swearing
in the garden is unreasonable
this can also be during the day during
early evening and late into the next
morning
my wife works from home in an office as
i'm sitting in at this moment
and at times during the day she cannot
work for the noise children screaming
and constant disturbances
we also have to endure the cooking
smells constantly coming across our
garden
from the extraction on the new extension
the smell of grease steak curries
um
you know the extraction equipment is
just not satisfactory and is ducted in
totally the wrong area
the children's play area is not managed
and is left open
to play on until late at night or at any
time because
anybody can walk into the garden at any
time
when it is dark children can be still
playing on the play equipment
unsupervised you can see this
um there is
no specific smoking area at the pub
and this comes across into our garden
and other people's gardens all through
the summer when the pub is open we have
not been able to sit in our garden or
conservatory because of the noise
we have not been able to enjoy our home
or garden for a very long time
you cannot watch tv in your lounge at
times because you get ground out by the
sound of the live music
um
you know and this causes stress
and
general sort of
bad feeling
mr lang's proposed application indicates
live music from 7 p.m till midnight
indoors
um whilst this is going on he has the
doors and windows open
you know which is basically now a pub
with no walls
um our bedroom is at the back of the
house and faces the new extensions
um you know does a restaurant need to be
open until midnight
i don't know of many restaurants that
are open until midnight
um
recorded music is often playing from 11
a.m in the morning until 11 p.m at night
with again all of the doors open
um
friday and saturdays
it can be midnight 1am
um we've had people in the garden until
two quarter to three before now
you know the upstairs of the building is
now being advertised as a function room
stroke event center
um
you know the supply of alcohol on friday
and saturday evenings
um until 1am
again is not acceptable for
what's classed as a restaurant stroke
gastro pub
because the planning finishing granted
was for a restaurant
you know these are not the hours you
expect from a
small
village
pub
mr lang's objectives
for his new planning application the
prevention of public nuisance
he states monitoring will take
place both inside and outside of the
licensed premises
and with due regard to the activity um
you know we've had excessive noise hence
mid suffolk have monitored that and
deemed it to be a statutory nuisance
um you know it's not just our property
this effects this affects other
neighbours as well
um he also states that appropriate
remedial steps will be taken and
recorded in the event of excessive noise
why hasn't this been done in the past if
that's the case
he also states that live and recorded
music events after 21 he will close all
of the doors and windows they shouldn't
ever be open when you've got that going
on
um you know why do you want to live with
constant noise when we can't enjoy our
homes and gardens
you know mr lang does not take any of
these things into account and his
actions um prove otherwise
you know um we have had karaoke events
um
i have never noticed any notices being
displayed on the on the pub with regards
to asking people to leave quietly
um and i know that there's none in the
garden um to that effect either whereas
many many licensed premises do have such
things
um he also states that the children's
player should only be used when
supervised
responsible adults well this isn't the
case never has been
um and it doesn't happen now and
even as recently as the weekend
you know
he states um that close residents are
kept informed of the programme of events
um well
i don't understand what that means or
where that comes from because it's not
the case
um
if mr lang had carried out the
objectives he is proposing for the
license application then the issues we
have been experiencing past five years
wouldn't have been occurring and we
wouldn't be in this situation we're
speaking to you about now
nor would there be a noise abatement
order in her place
um you know even since receiving the
notice we've had football playing
to the garden with all of the doors open
which i appreciate that was a
rare occasion with england but even so
you know not everybody wanted to have it
broadcasted across the village and into
their garden and home from somebody else
we've had an elvis tribute act
again with the doors and windows open it
was so loud it was thumping through them
through our lounge
you know
you know we just can't see where these
objectives are going to be met unless
there is some form of
licensing in place
to negate that
um you know i have to get up quite early
in the morning as i'm a tradesperson
um some nights you know on a friday
and saturday i've been kept awake until
three o'clock in the morning
you know um you know i just find that
totally
unacceptable
um i've spoke to mr lang in the past
about these things um and all he ever
does is give us a negative attitude with
regards to
um you know why don't you come around
and enjoy yourself
um or was the effect that
um when we spoke to him and said we'd
have no no um alternative but to you
know get mid suffolk district council
involved he actually said to my wife
well good luck with that
um
you know the amount of years and time
these issues have been going on
um you know as we said earlier it does
have a serious effect on you know our
health and well-being
you know we've seen legal advice with
regards to you know what's going on
um and you know the way the new
extensions have been used
um you know and it's just you know
totally unacceptable um for what it's
being used for as opposed to what it was
actually granted planning finishing for
thank you
thank you very much for that mr scott um
your presentation certainly amplified uh
knowledge towards us as opposed to
the information verbally given um
earlier you say about the children's
play area that you've noticed
um
are they young children playing in this
area after nine o'clock at night
because obviously one of our objectives
is protection of children from harm
i'll be honest you can have you can have
any age of children in in the children's
play area but children that are sort of
um 10 11 12 plus they get bored with the
equipment that's there so they then
start running around the walls
jumping over the walls slamming the gate
slamming the bolt backwards and forwards
on the gates um you know because the
north founders the play area is not very
big
but the amount of children that actually
congregate in it at times i mean it's
just
it's unbelievable the amount of noise
and we're talking about an area that is
only
the other side of a six-foot wooden
fence
and um how many
times have the mid-suffolk
officers been out to attend
yourselves with regards to noise
well for any of the issues that you've
raised
any of the issues i've raised probably
half a dozen times now but they don't
always they haven't always been able to
come out when we've requested
for whatever reasons
and i notice um in the um
the submission by mr lang
i just can't find it this second but a
contact number should be made readily
available
um do you have a contact number and have
you used that number in the past to
express concerns
to mr lange
[Music]
we've never been given a number but when
you do speak to mr lang he's just
downright rude
well
right that's your opinion there okay
that's my questions at the moment um i
will ask a counselor muller um i
wondered if you had some questions
having heard some more information
yes um thank you chair uh mr scott um
you say that mr lang runs a number of
events during the evening although mr
lang says these are quite limited to
such one or two a month how many actual
live events have you actually witnessed
since the pubs were allowed to reopen
following the uh
uh relaxation of the the pandemic rules
thank you we've had
so since the pandemic rules we've had uh
two lots of elders
we've had three quizzes
um and we have a games night every
monday night
and we've had several private functions
that have been either in the garden or
in the upstairs extension with the doors
open
or even downstairs with the doors open
thank you mr scott no further questions
of this stage chair thank you
thank you councilman the councillor
brewster
you have to unmute yourself again i'm
afraid i am
sorry
um
yeah i'm interested in
you appear
to be the only uh complainant but how
many others
complain to you about it or you know i'd
be interested in that
just to see what the level of complaints
are
could could you say that again please
i'm sorry sorry yeah you appear to me to
be the only complainant but i'm sure you
know of others who are
and that that's just
sorry i've got to interject here if
someone else has made a complaint then
we can consider it i don't believe
we can go on some kind of psa evidence
i'm happy for you to ask questions about
mr scott's um vicinity he may be the the
closest one to the premises or something
like that but um
i don't think you should be asking
questions about how many people have
complained to him is how many people
have complained made representations
i have no problems with the question yes
we are the nearest
um and we're certainly much nearer to it
than we used to be because of the new
extensions
yeah okay okay
thank you
i've got nothing further
um kay do you have any further questions
no thank you chair
and um
um mr
andy ruston edwards do you have any um
further questions for uh mr scott
no questions for mr scott chair
right
um
well in that case then we've heard
everything that we can hear
and so it would now be able to mr lang
may have questions he had an opportunity
sorry mr lane yes your questions i was
going to ask him to sum up actually but
mr lane do you have any questions for mr
scott
uh sorry no thanks
in that case then we've had all the
questions at the moment well at the
moment it's now up to you mr lane to sum
up what you've heard
so that the committee can look at the
evidence yet again that we have before
us and hear anything further that you
feel
would assist us in coming to our
decision
as i said i've been at the pub for 28
years
um
i feel we run
a very good pub
and
the ball games on the monday night is
less than six people
um as i said ball games they're hardly
going to make any noise playing ball
game um
and the children's player is um
we asked parents to
um
one of our children because for under 12
so
you know it's
you don't get older children and 12
going in there um
the ventilation system is brand new
um
which is only installed with a new
kitchen in 2019
um
so and the licenses
as it is i'm happy to work with
environmental health on the
um controlling any noise and that sounds
perfectly fair
uh
we've reduced the hours because the
hours were set i think punched on the
original um
licensing back in 2003. as they done all
the licensing and so that was a bit very
very much outdated and that license um
so yeah i'm happy to work with
mid suffolk and environment how to
um sort any problems
that's all really
thank you um nigel i've actually asked
mr lane to sum up before i ask the
licensing offer to give a closing
statement um
can we ask the officer and then uh just
once again ask mr lane if he has
anything further to add once he's heard
that that'll be fine yeah yeah it's okay
if you would like to just do that and
then i'll come back to you again mr lane
thank you chair um i don't have anything
else to summarize i just have one one
question if i may um
the emirates bill would like to make a
comment is that possible or can i make
that comment for her
nigel your comment please
if it come through the licensing officer
yes okay it was just a point regarding
um the doors and windows being shut it
just goes against the public protection
side of the covet issue of having to
have ventilation
well that's something
to be made just to put also
we understand that
that concludes i have nothing else to to
summarize on thanks thank you mr lane
just finally you are entitled to finish
before we go off to our um
other meeting to discuss the matters so
anything further to add from your goods
oh yeah just one thing um this um
uh thought that we were open till three
in the morning i cannot recall ever
being open until three in the morning
that's ridiculous just
um rarely go past 11 o'clock even at the
weekend the only time we might go over
11 o'clock is if we have an event on and
as it says an event is or something we
do
maybe half a dozen times a year
um
certainly wouldn't go over time for
darts pool
um ball game night
you know it's just ridiculous
as i said with closed normally i'd say
probably
between 10 and 11 most days
no no no mr scott no no um mr lane has
his final say so that we can make a
make a decision on what we've heard from
yourself and mr lane
so anything further mr lane no
no that's all thank you
thank you very much indeed
right
so i think we've all had sufficient time
to put the case forward
and i must put forward the following
motion
on the basis that the subcommittee
considers that the public interest in
excluding the public outweighs the
public interest in its deliberation
being held in public
it is resolved that under section 100a
brackets iv of the local government act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for item six on the grounds that
it involves the likely disclosure of
exempt information as defined in part
one of schedule 12 of the act on the
ground set out in regulation 14 2 of the
licensing act 2003
brackets hearings regulations 2005.
have a proposer and a seconder to that
happy to propose chair thank you
thank you council mother and have it a
second chair
thank you councillor brewster
so at this point um if all of the guests
remain where they are
we will leave the meeting and
have a separate meeting as we retire
and we will come back and give you our
determination
thank you
so i think
if i'm correct robert you're going to
pause the whole thing and
we will
well thank you very much everyone for
your patience um and we've had
some good deliberations and i will now
ask the legal adviser to
announce the decision of the committee
thank you
uh thank you chair um
as you can imagine it's been quite a
lengthy conversation um and the members
certainly acknowledge and accept that mr
and mrs scott have suffered from the
effects of noise
from the premises
um now
carefully considering this
and with minor adjustments to some of
the requested hours
and
an amendment to one of the conditions
and an addition of another condition
and
having carefully looked at the operating
schedule and the conditions in those
in which mr scott himself to say if
these conditions were complied with
then there shouldn't be a problem
so
the subcommittee is satisfied that it
can issue a license
subject to the following changes
um the the hours are
only slightly amended and they only
relate to the new year's eve hours
so therefore the live music and recorded
music has applied as applied for granted
the late night refreshment um has been
amended on the new year's eve to a
terminal hour of oh 100.
the supply of alcohol
terminal out for new year's eve is to
owe 100 and the hours open um on new
year's eve is amended to 0 100.
but more significantly it's the um
the amendment of the conditions
and the the amendment of the condition
is the condition contained in appendix a
under the the general conditions box a
where
the premises license holder shall ensure
that the outdoor area is marked on the
premises license plan with the use of
the garden stroke outdoor drinking area
ceases at 2400 on any given day that's
going to be amended to 2300
so that area should not be used
after 11 p.m
and there is the additional condition
and
uh
careful consideration was given in
respect of
the situation we had with covid however
there are no
actual regulations um
this is guidance at the moment but you
know this was carefully considered
but this uh the following condition is
to be added and that is to close all
windows and doors
at any time live music or recorded music
is being played
the subcommittee carefully considered
the the suggested that all doors and
windows should be closed from
9 30
every evening but felt
the current situation
um
it was probably best to to allow those
doors to to remain open while there was
no live music
or recorded music being played
clearly that you know that that may help
and it
may sort of prove that as time goes on
there isn't an issue when there's no
music being played and
we can get by with that but obviously
we may be back
in the future
as mentioned you know
uh earlier that
mr lane said that he was happy to
discuss and consult with the council's
environmental protection team to look at
managing um the noise um emanating from
the property
in particular the the effect that it has
on on number four king fisher
and you're strongly encouraged to to
cooperate with
environmental
services in that respect
so that is the um the terms on which
the the license applied for has been
granted
any party that's made that the
application or made any representation
to this subcommittee can appeal against
um
any aspect of the application as granted
or any condition that that's been
imposed
and such an appeal should be made to the
magistrates court within 21 days of
receiving written notification
and that's the decision back to you
chair
thank you very much indeed and
you will get your written response mr
lane so you will see everything clearly
laid out for you and i'd like to thank
you for your time and uh for mr scott's
time and the officers
presenting everything to us and so i
would now like to close the meeting and
thank you very much to everyone
thank you
you